well there have been
several incidents
two really serious ones that stick in
the mind
uh first one was in 1982
when the volcano mount gullum gong
went off and there was a british airways
flight
that
was flying at 36 000 feet and all the
engines stopped
and the pilots
had a nightmare over time but they they
got down to about 11 000 feet
and they they managed to restart the
engines
the second case was
about seven years later over mount red
out in alaska
in that case they were at about 40 000
feet all four engines stopped
and eventually they managed to restart
and uh
make a safe landing
before the um gulengong
incident we all thought it was oh you
just get a bit of a bit of wear on these
blades because it's sandy and evasive
and you might block up some holes in the
turbines
that of course is a long-term
deterioration it doesn't stop the
engines
the thing that stops the engines and
there was a a very
long and careful investigation
after both the events but there was a
huge report in the
u.s geological survey which is
interesting that it's the geologists
getting involved as well as the
engineers
which shows that the
contents of these volcanic clouds
contain a lot of
particles which are rather like glass
and what happens is that
these particles they enter the engine
and they get to the combustion chamber
here
which is like a furnace
well over a thousand degrees centigrade
the particles get into the combustor and
then this
liquid glass which is a sort of thick
syrupy liquid sprays over the turbines
and it um
partially blocks the air passages so
that um the right amount of air can't
get to can't get through the engine
anymore that's the fan
which sucks air in that's the compressor
which compresses it then it
the fuel is squirted into the combustor
where which of course gets very hot and
then the hot gases expand out to the
turbines
and the turbines are there to to drive
the compressor and it's the
the nozzle guide vanes here and the
turbine blades that follow that are
covered in the glass i mean the damage
to the compressors is quite serious but
it isn't that which shut the engine down
yes i went to a talk by the
the pilots of the the gun gun
event
who told a very moving and
dramatic story
but
the first thing they saw was
sort of sparks and a glow of light in
front of the windscreen and the
passengers could see flashes of light
from the wing leading edges
and streaks of flame
or in orange light coming out of the
both the back and the front of the
engines
which was all these particles glowing
the effect was to
sort of sandblast the windscreen so they
couldn't see through it anymore when
they came into land they had great
difficulty and one of the pilots was
standing up and talking to the other
pilot and they were like there was just
a tiny
lit clear bit of glass right at the edge
of the windscreen
and
they came in you know basically on
instruments but for the last bit you do
need to see where you're going
some people might think they're being
overly cautious by grounding all these
planes what do you think about that the
gun gun passengers formed an association
and have formed the club and having been
on an airplane for i think it was
something more than 11 minutes without
power and writing notes to your nearest
and dearest and thinking you end had
come
now at least two plane loads of
passengers have had that experience
and i don't think anybody else would
like the experience
the aero engine manufacturers do all
they can to
to cope with the effects of dust but
there's no way you can cope with coating
your turbine in glass it's just
all you can do is
just avoid it and and all the
effort since has been
keep out of the clouds